and when I find it interesting that you
know we've entered this new realm where
you know vampires zombies and and the
fear of witches within certain groups or
that someone has secret powers has now
become very prevalent in a lot of teen
movies and fiction can you talk about
that you've heard of the Age of Aquarius
okay in the precession of the equinoxes
you've got about 2,000 156 years /
astrological sign pisces was the age
before this one and it was all about
devotion and idealism so you see the
rise of the major religions in the last
2,000 years and all the beautiful art
and the music that was all based on that
idealism so when you come to the age of
aquarius which is coming in now it's the
age of the magician so in in all the old
lore you moved from the age of Aries
which is back in the classical warrior
times and Aries is the warrior right so
you had all those stories about you know
the Iliad and the Odyssey and the
warrior gods then the Age of Pisces was
about religion and priestly miss and the
whole idealized aspects of religion with
of course the dark side in there to you
know see more of the Crusades and all
the bloody wars it really isn't much of
a surprise that we're seeing so many
more of these types of stories if you
take the perspective that it is the age
of aquarius is the age of the magician
it is the age of spirit into matter and
so many people would say well it's just
this is just the natural progression of
what's going on in the cosmos certainly
on the earthly realm and many people
were predicting it actually if you look
at some of the metaphysical writings
from the turn of the century and even up
to the 1950s turn of the last century
and up to the mid-century they're always
talking about how there's going to be
more
magic and more magicians come the Age of
Aquarius and that the first hundred and
twenty-five years of that shift because
the is with anything changing you've got
that phase change that period where the
old isn't gone yet and the new isn't
quite solidified yet and what do you see
today you see the battle between the old
idealism religion aspects and the new
magician manipulation of matter and law
that science is in there too but the
metaphysicians would explain it as we're
in the cross over time and so a lot of
people who are more in the ideal system
are going to find this new system a
threat and when when you talk about
witches you know and somebody says well
you know why do people what's the whole
thing about thinking somebody's a witch
and often it's either they're jealous or
they're afraid remember the witch hunts
of Europe and America and no not too
many centuries ago and just like though
with any kind of dictatorial system or
any kind of oppressive controlled system
you give people a chance to report on
other people to turn them in to reveal
them as a communist or as an
intellectual you've got a lot of people
out there with petty little gripes and
they're going to do it they're going to
point the finger because humans can
sometimes be pretty venal and tacky and
mean and so you give people a big target
and they're going to throw everything
against it on the other hand the fear
side I think most of us fear what we
don't understand yeah that's just human
nature so if somebody seems to be doing
something that you don't understand and
you are afraid of that just in hair
Lee then you're going to start pulling
together more explanations for it
couldn't possibly be that she's just
smarter she must have cast a spell to
get that job that I wanted it must be
witchcraft no not necessarily
you